mike florio kind enough to join me here
once again here on the rich eisen show
how are you mike
doing great rich how are you pal better
for talking to you um
let's let's start with i guess the
friday draft trades and all the intrigue
um that is now coming off of that um
did did the 49ers just peg the with the
dolphins at third overall
the guy who they want and never knock on
the door with the jets what can you tell
me about
all of all of their maneuverings at the
top of the draft and who it might be for
well it reminded me exactly of what the
jets did in 2018 when six weeks before
the draft they moved from number six
to number three they invested three
second round picks in that flip-flop
they did with the colts and
once you do that once you lock into that
spot what you are telling the world
is no matter who the first two picks are
we sufficiently
love whoever would be left over so if
you've got three guys
that you would gladly make your
franchise quarterback your guy for the
next 10 or 15 years
a player for whom you eventually are
giving up
three first round picks and a third
round pick and let's not
confuse that all this talk
in the current offseason about three
first-round picks is a starting point
for deshawn watson three first-round
picks offered for russell wilson
the 49ers will have given up three ones
and a three
to get this guy whoever it is and
they presumably would be thrilled if
trevor lawrence falls to three he won't
if zach wilson falls to three he likely
won't
and then they've got a third guy whether
it's mack jones whether it's justin
fields whether it's trade lance
there's a quarterback that they're happy
to take even after
the jaguars and the jets have secured
dibs on one and two
and it's clearly a quarterback after the
press conference yesterday with coach
kyle shanahan and gm john lynch it's
clearly a quarterback the question now
is who is it and they got 30 days to
continue to hold that close to their
vest and enjoy the fact
and this is part of it too rich they get
to enjoy the fact for the next 30 days
the 49ers and what they're going to do
with the third overall pick is all
anyone's going to talk about
it's free publicity for the brand for
the next 30 days
just like with the remember the rams
2016 jeff fisher loved every second of
having the first overall pick in the
draft and he wasn't telling anybody what
we already knew they were taking jared
goff
because he loved the fact that the rams
had the first overall pick in the draft
for weeks before they had to actually
call out a name well i mean justin
fields ran a 4-4-4
earlier today uh mike and it just led me
to
to you know take a take a pause on the
zach
wilson broadway zack or zack's fifth
avenue as i saw on my twitter feed
earlier today
um that that you know usually things
change and rumors fly and positions
change do you think it's possible that
the jets do have
some sort of intrigue at two overall
and and that includes eventually keeping
sam darnold that they're so damn close
to the vest
on all of this well
i think when zach wilson rolled right to
left and threw that laser down the field
on friday it is pro day yeah
that that probably ended any debate or
discussion about
what the jets who have been trying and
failing
since joe namath to have a franchise
quarterback a true franchise quarterback
year in and year out guy that's going to
make you a contender
when you see that mahomesey in quality
in a guy who's entering the nfl and
you've earned the spot not to trade up
you're there yes given up anything this
is the reward for being crap last year
this is great falling right in their
hands because the jaguars
are clearly taking trevor lawrence i got
a theory
rich and they make fun of me on the show
they call me conspiracy mike when i say
this but i got a theory that urban meyer
the jaguars coach
specifically didn't go to the zac wilson
pro day because he didn't want to have
any doubts in his mind
as he stood there and as he says like to
hear the ball come out of the guy's
hands he just didn't want to do it
he knows he's taken lawrence and he
doesn't want to have to reconsider or
reevaluate after he gets blown away by
zach wilson so i think it's definitely
wilson it too
the question is what does kyle shanahan
have up his sleeve at number three
well what's your best guess we're
hearing you know daniel jeremiah stopped
me in my tracks when he came on
yesterday and he says
that the the general consensus is mac
jones um
and that's that's the guy who everyone
was you know in new england was
targeting maybe belichick could just sit
in the middle of the first round and get
back jones and that now seems like an
official pipe dream
certainly seeing mac at his pro day
today what do you think about all that
the thing i love about mac jones and i
don't know whether it's the equipment
manager's fault in alabama
he just doesn't look like a football
player he doesn't look like his pads fit
he looks like andy reid at the ppk
competition
early 1970s right it's like bobby lane
joe cap
throw back but the guy can do it all the
guys got the footwork the guy's got the
accuracy the guy's got all the skills to
run kyle shanahan's offense and i'll
defer to
chris sims who played at texas with kyle
shanahan has known him for years and
even though shanahan won't tell sims
anything because he's a big mouth and a
blabbit
sims knows the way shanahan thinks and
he knows what quarterbacks are suited to
plug right in
to the shanahan offense and operate it
the way that shanahan wants it to be
operated that's the big thing
we share and i remember two thousand
eleven after the lockout ended
and there was question who the
quarterback was going to be in
washington when the contenders were like
john beck and
rex grossman grossman said i know how to
win this job
all i have to do is do exactly what
shanahan wants me to do
that's what he looks for he's basically
the kid with the joystick on the
sideline
with the quarterback doing exactly what
shanahan wants he's devised plays
that will work against the defenses that
he knows are coming
and you will win if you can just deliver
it the way that he wants and
and sims believes as do others
apparently that mac jones is the guy who
fits that criteria for kyle shannon so
if the jets are taking that offense with
them with robert sala
and mike lafleur why don't they take
mack jones since you want to have
broadway joe's successor finally be why
not
have it somebody from the same school
well well that's a good point and i
think if that would happen causing it
would be thrilled to have zach wilson
still on the board because i think
wilson is all that stuff plus
the cross body throw with one foot on
the ground no feet on the ground
all armed forget about the obsession
over mechanics
this is the guy who's got that short
stop quality that mahomes has
funny body motion any arm position
he can deliver the ball so it's
everything that mac jones has plus a
little bit more
not that not that it's a huge gap but
it's enough of a gap that my guess is
shanahan
shanahan would love it if there's some
sort of a jedi mind trick going on here
and the jets end up deciding that mac
jones is the right pick
and you know mike florio here on the
rich eisen show um
i don't know which is my favorite
soundbite from my uh kyle shanahan's
press conference
on monday him just being so honest about
you know
uh keeping jimmy g but if people
want to come and make the team better in
so many different ways of course they'll
listen
but you know free agency if they've
gotten a new quarterback in free agency
that's a different story than drafting a
rookie you don't want to be in a
position
of needing the rookie to do well when
you've got a veteran that the whole
locker room loves i mean it was so
refreshing to hear that honesty
and then being you know asked about the
attributes of a quarterback that he
might choose and
trying to extrapolate it to his love of
kirk cousins that answer was
phenomenal in honesty and then also
bristling at cousins being his
prototypical quarterback in the mind's
eye of the media and then
building cousins back up uh by the end
of a conversation where he realized he
was
toeing the line of tampering uh that was
phenomenal
i i'm wondering what you thought of that
well rich
the reason why patrick mahomes was never
considered to be
the pick for the 49ers at number two or
number three once they traded down with
the bears in 2017
is because kyle shanahan believed that
at the end of the 2017
season kirk cousins would become a free
agent as he did
washington was not going to tag him a
third time it would have been
34 million dollars which three years ago
was a ridiculous amount it still is
a lot to pay for a quarterback for one
year but they weren't going to pay that
to cousins
so shanahan was going to sign him so he
didn't evaluate mahomes didn't evaluate
desean watson didn't evaluate any of the
quarterbacks
because he thought he was getting
cousins and then the trade for jimmy
garoppolo goes down
during the 2017 season and that short
circuits cousins
so cousins i've had on shanahan's radar
screen
i thought that maybe this year now i
think the vikings had to keep cousins
around because
if they try to move to a new quarterback
that potentially could set that team
back and get everybody fired but yeah
there's been a sense that shanahan
wants a cousins and that cousins in the
right system
when you don't expect him to do too much
when you just expect him to do the
plates called and i had a head coach
explain this to me
kirk cousins can run the play that's
called
he can't run the play that isn't called
which the patrick mahomes aaron rodgers
kyler murrays of the world can do run
away from pressure and make something
happen
on a on an impromptu basis but
cousins can run the play that's called
and in shanahan's offense that's all you
need a guy who consistently
and effectively and accurately can run
the play that's called
and deliver the ball and with shanahan
often enough you're going to move the
ball and you're going to score points
and i think that's what he sees in mack
jones
and nick saban explained mac jones
attributes yesterday
and it almost sounded like he's saying
this guy's just a game manager but that
that's a good thing
if you have an offense that works all
you need is a game manager you need
someone to manage that offense and if
it's shanahan's offense and it works
that's how you win football games and
put yourself in championship positions
mike florio here
on the rich eisen show jenny verentis's
article on this
in sports illustrated speaking to um
a massage therapist under a pseudonym
um from houston talking about
desean watson and his behavior in her
in her massage room
and watson's and the fact that she
isn't part of this um this tony busby
uh group of uh accusers
um for the first time really made me
made me
pause um and it was very
um and i'm not saying that that i don't
believe others
accusers and that's obviously the the
razor's edge of this conversation here
but it really was bizarre and it you
can't sit here and say she's looking for
money
you can't sit here and say that she's
making it up with a lawyer
who started this whole thing on his
instagram account
um what do you think about all of this
well i agree with you completely the
fact that this is somebody who actually
rejected the overtures of busby's firm
and decided not to be represented
by busby and is evaluating her rights
with
another lawyer in houston and frankly
when you look at everything she said
there
isn't that bright line obvious
grounds for liability that some of the
lawsuits that have been filed most of
the lawsuits that have been filed if
the allegations in the lawsuits are
proven
there is liability on the part of desean
watson
so it does give credibility just to the
broader picture that's been painted by
19 lawsuits and now a 20th person
who hasn't sued and may not sue you know
rich if it's just two or three people
and you can show that one of them as
watson's camp apparently believes was
trying to extort that there was
consensual conduct whatever the case may
be if there's just
two or three and you can
blow a giant hole in one of the claims
that's one thing
you get up to 19 or 20 okay one of the
claims may have a flaw
you can't account for the rest and i
think that's the problem sean watson
faces at this point rich and the sooner
and i don't want anybody to
misunderstand me when i say this because
i think he needs to have a reckoning
he needs to make this right he needs to
make it right with all the individuals
involved i have been arguing for a week
now there needs to be a mediation
session where
everyone comes together to get a retired
judges got the gravitas
to make everyone feel like they're
getting a day in court and work directly
with
every plaintiff and desean watson to
bring
satisfaction closure a sense of justice
without a two-year process that's the
best outcome
for deshaun watson i just don't know
that he can manage that because
at the core of it all for the plaintiffs
is tony busby and no matter how much he
says it's not about money
it is about money and the problem now is
as watson's waking up rich to the
reality that it's in his interest to
resolve these cases now
from the perspective of a skilled and
experienced lawyer who is in it for
money
there's a premium if you want to do it
now and i think that's the challenge
trying to come up with a way
to get all these people in the same room
get this resolved and remove
from it the busby factor where he's
going to recognize
i've got this guy on the ropes so the
price of every settlement
goes way up so what what does the league
do under these circumstances mike
because again you know the the sports
illustrated
um story uh the
woman who told her story to sports
illustrated said watson never touched
her
and never threatened her and
his behavior as it was described is
nothing short of shocking
obviously there are two other uh or at
least
two other accusers who do say that he
did
force himself on them put them all
together
and you know how do you decide is is the
league going to wind up
having to decide whose story is
believable and who
isn't and what to do um with deshaun
watson
uh on this subject matter or or would a
settlement
make any sort of discipline from the
league
uh moot what what happens here
well if the simple question is what does
the league do
and i don't mean this to sound like a
smart ass response
but the league will do whatever the
league wants to do
because it has the discretion it has the
ability under the various policies to
fashion
whichever outcome it thinks is best
given these facts and the entire
personal conduct policy is driven by p
r ninety nine point nine nine percent of
all employers in america don't have
something like this that regulates the
private lives
of employees if you can show up for work
you got a job
if you're incarcerated and can't show up
for work you don't have a job
anything else that's between you and the
civil courts the criminal courts
whatever the case may be
for the most part the nfl and the nfl pa
have agreed to make this part of the
existence of an nfl player because it
does
affect how all players and teams in the
league are viewed in the unions on board
with it
and the league has the power to do
whatever it wants now i look at some
precedent and let me give you a couple
of examples
tyree kill a couple of years ago when
there were some troubling allegations
in the confines of the off-season
program happening they struck a deal for
him to just stay home
and then by the time training camp
rolled around he had gotten
whatever clearance he needed to get from
the criminal system
that it was okay to move forward ben
roethlisberger 2010
no arrests there was one civil suit that
was filed against him
in 2009 there was an incident in 2010
nothing ever happened from the
perspective of arrest charges
verdicts but the commissioner still said
there's enough here for me to be
troubled
and that's where i think this is rich
there's enough
there for the commissioner to be
troubled the question becomes at what
point
does the league say we have to take
action
we have to put you on the commissioner
example list or if it all would get
settled right now and this is why i
mentioned roethlisberger
if it all would get settled right now if
they have a mediation tomorrow and all
19 plaintiffs come out of that room
believing they got justice
and it's over and they're satisfied
there's still enough there based on
roethlisberger's case that the league
could say
deshaun this this requires an
intervention that's the word that
goodell used with roethlisberger we need
to take a closer look at this there
needs to be
discipline there needs to be action
there needs to be involvement
and there's already enough then this all
ends today
there's already enough for the
commissioner to suspend desean watson if
he chooses to do so all in the middle of
of watson saying he wants out all in the
middle of all
all of this where we spent weeks talking
about
his trade value and his worth and how
he's done playing for the texans
this just seems to be uh putting
everything on a totally different plane
on that front mike that's just the way i
feel i'm wondering if that's the reality
of it
it can't be traded after the first
lawsuit was filed the general manager
said to me how can anyone trade for him
now and i said what's this one lawsuit
no one's investigated it everyone's got
security resources at their disposal
they can figure this out they can look
into what they can get by the
time the draft rolls around to a point
where they understand it
but then when it becomes 2 and 5 and 7
and 11
and 15 and 19 you can't trade him and
the ultimate irony here would be and i i
never know whether i'm using that
word right thanks to atlantis more set
the ultimate irony would be
yes that deshaun watson said no way in
hell am i ever playing for the texans
and he wants out
and it could be the only way he gets
paid this year a football salary
is to stay with the texans and be put on
the commissioner exemplist
not play but still get his checks and at
some point the texans have to ask
themselves
do we just cut the cord and save the 10
million dollars
it all depends upon how bad it gets and
we're still too early to know how bad
it's going to get
and there may not be enough time between
now and training camp for it to get to
the point where it would be that bad
but it's look it's unprecedented from
the perspective
of i can't recall a situation like this
that any players ever had to deal with
and it looks like there's no simple
exit at this point for desean watson
mike who
what he got for later on pft p.m and
tomorrow
well peter king is joining me today for
pftpm
and there is a conference call with the
commissioner and
others at 3 30 eastern so whatever they
say
we will be summarizing reacting to
obviously we all expect a 17-game season
to be official and various details
related to that
plus whatever else they're doing today
as the owners get together so we'll have
that all covered coming up later at five
o'clock
and then of course tomorrow on pro
football talk and all the other shows
here on nbc sports on peacock uh
you know whatever rule changes might be
down the pike
um and uh we'll we'll talk about that
appreciate the time as always mike
great talking to you rich that's mike
florio